so today we're going to talk about what
if the universe is just a computer
simulation how would we know what sort
of things were we expect to see could we
ever tell could we ever be able to work
out that word you know living in part of
a simulation or were just bits of
information
courses The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy where for example the earth was
just massive computer program and all
the people on it form part of how did
they put it the organic matrix does the
matrix of course itself which is a
really really intriguing idea really
intelligent concept let down by some the
earth or acting it's a fascinating
concept for anybody are we living in a
simulation and it stretches all the way
back it's a philosophical a thorny
philosophical issue so there's a whole
sort of something of physics now called
digital physics where physicist and
computer scientists are getting together
and the idea is that the fundamental
basis of reality the fundamental basis
of physics is not energy it's not matter
its information and there's a guy called
John Wheeler back in the 70s that is
wonderful phrase called it from bit the
most fundamental aspect of our reality
is information this is physics world
back in just last year modeling our
universe is a giant computer and the
idea here is that instead of having
what's called continuous functions
instead of being able to basically pick
any particular point in space no matter
how small Dan didn't the smallest
infinitesimal there's a quantization
space is divided up into chunks or space
is divided into a grid and that's really
reminiscent of things that were
happening again back in the 70s but have
been you know obviously developments in
the decades since then where the
something called Conway's Game of Life
which is a really really neat example of
how simple rules very simple rules can
give rise to complexity and what you do
is you set up a grid it could be in
three dimensions but generally in
Conway's Game of Life would consider two
dimensions and what you do is something
really really simple really simple rooms
right what we're going to do is we're
going to populate this grid so we have
squares which are like little animals
and I know he's really simple rules what
you basically see so you start off your
system and what you're going to do is
each time round we get a computer to
this but there's no reason if you were
suitably inclined and had nothing better
to do with your life that you couldn't
do with just pen and paper you look at
this one you know you look at each
animal or each cell let's call them
cells in the grid and you say look look
at the many neighbors it's got and then
you have very simple rules if it's got
zero or one neighbors it dies out alone
in us if it's got more than four
neighbors it dies out of overpopulation
overcrowding and if it's got two or
three then it's happy so that's those
those one set of rules if it's occupied
if it's not occupied if it doesn't have
a cell in it then what happens is that
if it's got three neighbors so here for
example then what will happen is this
one will become live if you do this I'll
show you in the screen this is some
obviously it's gonna take a long time if
we were to do that with pen and paper
John Conroy's game of life by a guy
called where is it Martin Edwin Martin
so what you do is let's take a really
simple one like that and what we're
going to do is we're going to play those
rules and watch what happens you might
think oh this is gonna be fairly boring
but so you get something which is called
a glide or just due to the way those
those rules work okay so in this case
once it reaches the edge of the grip the
edge of the grid things effectively stop
so let's do this one and let's see what
happens now Wow
remember how basic those rules are my
daughterís of seven and nine my sons
actually fought I could explain those
rules to him and see what you got there
this case it reaches a steady stay at a
boring studies did but before let's run
that again you saw that complexity just
from very basic rules stop it again and
then or we can do something completely
random let's clear it
Edwin's provided the facility to do need
things like this that's a very wonky
face and then we run this same rules and
what you see is the population so this
is I hope you can see how it's way it's
called game of life now and in the 70s
you know this was paradise for geeks you
know this was steer to the art computer
graphics in the 70s in fact I my
computing started in the eighties with
something called the zx81 this is in
collar
this is far beyond what I was capable of
back in 1981 so on this would have been
heaven for me but notice so in this case
this once keeps flicking around and it
will do that for infinity but what's
remarkable here is unbelievably simple
rules on a grid on this type of grid
give rise to this type of complexity and
what's the important thing here well
it's the information it's the the fact
that this this animal or this whatever
you want to call it sell at this
position is affected by it it's
influenced by its neighbors and it's the
it's those interactions and how that
information is exchanged that gives rise
to this level of complexity and
physicists in all seriousness not all of
not all physicists are allowed to
certainly admit that there's a large
number who would seriously doubt this
and would argue that actually at the
most fundamental level space-time
reality amongst us around us is not a
grid like this it is not quantized but
computer scientists physicists a large
number of those are arguing well
actually no it may well be like this and
then it becomes very very interesting
indeed as to how these basically these
rules play out so what this has got to
do it you and me and atoms and galaxies
is that the important thing here is if
the system depends just solely on well
whether it is this unit is this grid
occupied or not is that a 1 or a 0
is that a bit or is it not a bit then do
we treat particle interactions like that
these are those physics is reasonably
well developed there are it has its
proponents that has its opponents but
the idea that space-time might be
quantized what are the zeros and ones
what's the equivalent like are you
talking about like atoms of the bits or
it's not it's the fundamental particles
it's the idea that right at the very
limit of very smallest thing you can
imagine like the Planck length at that
level we're talking we're seeing that
that space is quantized you know these
are ones and zeros if it's occupied it's
a 1 if it's not occupied it's a 0 and
what's the equivalent of
keep Arden unoccupied at the quantum
level in there the presence for example
the presence of a priority call the
absence of a particle
what slightly more left to field and
slightly more off-the-wall but
nonetheless interesting is could we be
actually the result of a computer
simulation by some super hyper
dimensional or whatever set of aliens or
indeed future generations could we be
living in future and there's a guy
called Nick Bostrom at Oxford at the
future of humanity Institute in Oxford
who's proposed something called a
simulation argument who argues this
you've got three options first of all
one is that we don't expect we don't
reach we saw at some point we blow
ourselves up of global warming comes
along and we wipe ourselves out
relatively boring steady-state second
one is that what okay we get lots and
lots of technology but we just sort of
lose interest in for example trying to
run simulations at larger and larger and
larger simulations but the third one and
the third one is the most interesting
one is well we develop better and better
technology and what that technology
allows us to do is you run better and
better simulations up to the point where
we can simulate an entire universe if
you can simulate an entire universe and
if really what matters right at the
bottom end of this is whether you fill a
grid with ones and zeros that's
computing then and if our consciousness
and our sentience stems from that then
what you'll do is you create sentient
beings in a supercomputer awesome and
the argument is that if you do have that
type of technological capability of
Bostrom's argument is that it's
exceedingly likely if we do progress to
that point that we are in a simulation
this is not reality this is a simulator
rely and you can think of layers upon
layers upon layers of simulations and
how would we ever know we'd like to
thank audible.com for its support of
this computer file video audible has a
massive range of audio books and if
you're someone like me who has to go on
a lot of long drives or walk the dog
everyday it's great being able to catch
up with books on a portable device like
your iPhone - recommendations after a
video like this Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy
and also firemen's physics lectures and
the good thing about these two is you
can actually listen to the guys who
wrote the books fireman himself and
Douglas Adams which is always a nice
trait hearing their voices you can
download a free audiobook at audible.com
slash computerphile so go and check it
out and thanks to audible for supporting
channels like this it's great for us to
be able to team up with a company that's
selling books and information and also a
company that kind of uses technology and
things like that things we love here at
computerphile
so while you go and get free audio book
I'm gonna get this thing rolling well
that's a nice one